you want to live hard you want to live
clean you want to live optimized we know
there's one company that does not
compromise you know I'm saying are you
rapping right yeah it happened must be
on alpha brain you were talking about on
it bro on everything yes dude on it calm
slash fight or a little alpha brain
little new mood maybe you want some
melatonin really want to sleep better
yeah man how about some creatine so we
can get Jack city how about shroom tech
immune or how about just shroom tech and
general if you want to work out extra
how about a little krill oil to get that
skin right literally everything you want
including exercise about fitness gear
they got it check you want some Star
Wars on it kettlebells one mallets ropes
bags balls clubs maces how about you
need a training program we got that on
it six kettlebell on it 6 steel mace
they got it all streaming easy apparel
shirts shorts backpacks socks
performance gear audit comp slash
fighter 10% off get yourself
hey B there's a lot of tools out there
that track your heart rate they might do
a thing here or there maybe you're on a
bike like I am I'm like damn I burned a
thousand calories but I'm not yeah or
how about you think you're getting good
rest you think you're doing the things
right you think a good diet but you're
not really tracking it right you're not
tracking with the best device possible
you mean you talk about whoop what about
will form is tool change the way people
track the fitness and optimize their
training it really is kind of amazing I
mean before I even knew about it you
were wearing it and I said you you were
you're comparing it to other I've had a
bunch of watches yeah and you said this
was the best by far the bed you were a
customer before you this this became
select loop is a performance tool you
get a whoop strap which is a heartrate
monitor that measures your heart rate a
hundred times per second 24 hours all
that stuff 24/7 you can charge it while
you want you don't even take it off just
put on the little battery it charges it
usually lasts about five days mine last
a little longer so five days without a
charge yeah so what's would measure like
what am I gonna do though your recovery
look at your heart rate you make sure
you're getting the right rest if you're
not zero your strain how well you're
working out it checks your resting heart
rate max heart rate calories burned the
of exertion you're putting out
throughout the day your sleep - all that
REM deep light it does all that man it
provides all these insights down to the
nitty gritty and you got to get the new
woop 3.0 strap that's what you need to
do go to whoop go to whoop comm whoop
there it is
wh Oh Oh Pete calm use the code fighter
at checkout save $30 to optimize the way
you train again that's woop comm promo
code fighter for $30 off the way you
gotta do it right to track your training
get to shred Sadie needs you agent
I'm just started foursome to start all
my foursome for some force them hey bro
hey man what are you doing dude just
texting man I'm just texting I'm busy
I'm always doing business bro I'm
starting off Monday like oh you know
what I mean like I wake up and then that
it's like Monday and people like oh it's
Monday I start I'm like let's start
money like oh you know look like you're
at the first day of orientation for
college with that sweatshirt
don't say that dude because the old guys
going back no this is like this is a
cream this is a cream sweatshirt from
rusev I call it crumbles at the abbot
kinney Fight Club do you remember we
talked about the softest thing I've ever
felt ever yeah I doubt that playboy I
swear out besides I don't know say it
sometimes they are sometimes they're
terribly soft sometimes they're even
hard they're soft
well I know what you mean so sensitive I
suppose it is back to the strip though
dude you remember when we started
advocating Fight Club yeah remember I
came up with the idea from wild card
Boxing I didn't know that how you came
out of the idea I just remember you said
yeah he's part of the advocating Fight
Club is the first thing you said and I
was like oh that's kind of cool
advocate I'm wearing my a bikini fight
the ritual members are you me kind of
founder
yeah no no holder don't say that don't
take credit going through it you're not
allowed to just take credit for me start
it found it
me Sasso DeLeo it was really just you
and me cuz we used that on not really
cuz we used to hang out on a bikini and
drink coffee you remember I remember
that green tea
they had this Suntory or some [ __ ] first
flush oh seven Tori long that [ __ ] no
was this green remember that was like a
green buttery T intelligence yes it was
so [ __ ] ridiculously good but it
would always hang out it's seasonal I
know cuz we'd sit there and we'd go to
juste uh we'd go to like intelligentsia
we've got a jewelry a takeaway we got to
start doing that more I know I was over
there last week for my photos show I'm
like I don't get over here enough man I
want my son growing up around some of
though it's the best the best I agree I
love it there
I [ __ ] me too man love it I feel at
home when I'm there I do too because
it's like I think a lot of it has to do
with like it's scaled around human
beings like those stores that it's much
it's small nothing is no mainstream
stuff now there's no fast food
restaurants right I went to juice that
was kind of packed and the first thing I
was like [ __ ] I wish Brian was here yeah
and beer my girl like why I'm like we
wouldn't have to wait he's mr. Venice
I'm the mayor yeah you just come in
there and we like never waste so much of
it is changing though in a lot of ways
but it's also there are the pores what
the poor people the poor people the poor
how well there's a lot of hey no man
there's a lot of homeless not not down
Abbot so much anymore now but there's a
lot of homeless and vent rug addicted if
you run in Venice in the morning when
ice run peer-to-peer from marina to
Santa Monica when I live down I'd run
that walking Weiss a week it's the
walking back it looks like the purge in
the morning there's no one out it's just
homeless but you see because they're
there just set up you're everywhere yeah
if you go to Portland if you go to
Seattle if you go to Los Angeles if you
go to San Francisco it's so out of
control and I I so so their blood
main thing is is this a product of the
opiate thing as this is a product of
because is it or is it awesome well it's
not so all these as we're starting to
[ __ ] yeah they're but except for
you're seeing medieval diseases return
like leprosy for real leprosy
they found leprosy in in some of these
homeless those you're finding like
really weird Oh bubonic plague and
leprosy in these in these chances and by
the way they hurt business they hurt
real estate values oh I'm all for
treatment but if you've got massive
colonies and no and there's zero
enforcement how many of them are just
lazy well they talked a lot of up tube
addicts
yeah and mental health which I'm sure
that yeah the majority but how many are
just lazy so the guy wake up go [ __ ]
yeah but the guy in Seattle who is
really studies this he was I think was a
former cop but he's in it he's helping
them he's working with them and then he
and another woman said essentially look
100% the drug use in an addiction is not
95 it's 100 percent opiate its meth it's
it's math its opiates it's everything
it's it's everything they can get their
hands on its booze and so when you see
this you're like okay so we've got a
massive population of drug-addicted
walking dead you know people what do you
do about it when the one thing you can't
do is just let it fester and grow all
these massive colonies because there is
a lot of crime there you gotta kill yeah
it's in the business of difference wait
wait whoa whoa whoa hold on hold on dude
[ __ ] no you gotta say he'll the disease
okay but you said we gotta kill them
feels your first dog to be misquoted
like how would you gotta kill that you
can get helicopter gunships can you
someone call Tim Kennedy oh my god it's
a disease it's funny cuz in Brazil
apparently they caught they caught them
a long time ago
where they did have they were killing
these people yeah don't they yeah the
other their killerman bridges and stuff
right underneath it children my fire its
offerings
awful man this is not children this is
[ __ ] real real drug addition people
and I don't know what time we did take a
bat Kenny back we need great advocating
what we need you donated you know you
could do you could so no I know I'm
gonna do like these almost people but
you know I'm gonna do with that but
Kenny Fight Club well I'm gonna recreate
a new shirt it's time to realize think
so time to relaunch that I think so dude
cuz we have to advocating Fight Club
hoodies with roots of fight they get
those new jackets that are yeah but out
which are stupid sick yep
but I replace they're anywhere in a
bikini I wonder where we could do an
actual inclusive and exclusive right
love but a stand-up night ooh you know
what I mean and if you're a part of the
a big movie Fight Club you're you're one
of the rare comics right what we
showcase new and young with that as
comics around there though well that
sound there are there are some cool are
there any theater yes there are some
cool the electric club on Electric
Avenue right behind a bikini is it a
white guy it's not a white guy so I
ain't that ain't that Bobby Ferran or
something we got a rock down to Electric
Avenue and then we'll take you higher
well yeah definitely a person of African
descent yeah there you go there you go
Eddie grant
god dammit no I got a whole bunch that
makes sense
hit it dude oh we gettin kicked off
nevermind you know what you're not
talking about Venice nah he's probably
Jamaican from Jamaica you know from
Jamaica no but oh look the groves on the
motorcycle oh maybe not in the street
there is violence Tony found a somewhat
to be done where's Caribbean yeah he was
it about Venice this whole time no I
look at a smart TV derp
that they are watched that was a long
time ago see I don't know that could be
Venice 20 Street NT 23 million pricing
the notion of Mardi tree million-plus
news
Sall our hands get Jamna I got so
disappointed it's not advocate yeah it's
a good idea we should do a show up live
Kenny I think so I really do I think
it'd be just do a special at one night
so you need you and I natural shirt yeah
but you and I need to do Wednesday's
together the bronze of Venice
underground Bronson his so we'll just
have to me it was that uh John Varvatos
and guy was a cop do you ever do the
Venice Thunder good my favorite my would
be in many ways my favorite room to do
there's just something beautiful about
that it'll be yeah we got to do I'm
gonna bring Rogan down there to set it
up yeah I will brought Bronson's already
Reese's down for it so it's been looking
great I love it I'm down dude
all right I'm down bro make a real show
dude I was in Houston I got a little
worried man with the flood so I was a
have to cancel day of I went to Austin
and the Thursday night everyone was like
do not come down here wait there's
floods some fan sent me a picture of
their car literally floating away like
floating in the ocean away what tonight
dude do not come do not come and then I
posted on my social media as a cake for
reals how bad is it
and a shitload of people hit me up and
with like eight not that bad not that
bad at all get down here with our system
flooding system it's way better now
let's go through Brendan's Instagram
right now let's start with the tour go
go through what go through now you know
what dude you're Road Dogg Road Dogg I'm
impressed with that alot go through his
let me read his his [ __ ] let's go to
his Instagram we're gonna go through the
whole first started to the first 104 the
cuz I got stuff to see this post okay so
watch this hit that song for so Denver
Pittsburgh right a Philadelphia Dallas
Salt Lake Kansas City Atlantic City San
Diego Oklahoma City Connecticut Boston
San Diego San Antonio Chicago I don't
need glasses and look at this at 52
everything you say is a charlatan
Columbus Atlanta New Orleans Toronto
Detroit New York Washington DC
Tacoma Cork Ireland over her Dublin
Ireland Belfast Ireland Glasgow
Glasgow Scotland London Newcastle
Newcastle Birmingham Birmingham
Manchester that's up in the North
Manchester Cardiff Cardiff is is
somewhere in England yep I think Sweden
Sweden Sweden Stockholm and Gothenburg
Guttenberg Oh Amsterdam you're gonna
[ __ ] live never been there I can say
my dick sir Norway but dude I want to
come with you to Sweden amps Neiman
Norman I really how much fun with that
but really I for real wanted do you
think I could join otter person I can't
pay you but you hundred percent well let
me come in and we'll get a bigger venue
and let's pull our resources right now
if we launch this tour but man let me
get in there
it would be fun I don't want to go there
alone I want to go there I don't want
y'all alone either I would go with you
for real I would 100% go to Sweden and
stand in our way
I really would when is it I don't we
just add shows III I'm down I'm down for
that
why don't we do that that's a good I
will 100% well it'll come with you to
Sweden Amsterdam in Norway mmm cuz I
want I've never been I've been to Sweden
I've never been Amsterdam I never been
to Norway I've never been in the
Amsterdam I hear is my hazing and not
because of the red-light district I
heard there
I heard the red-light district is
amazing yeah but there's you know there
I can't I can't purchase a young lady in
a window I'm just not doing it makes me
sad they're in windows and you can
purchase them don't do that with your
face to do you look you have an
enthusiastic nod let's see the red light
district in Amsterdam there in April so
the the the I kicked off April look at
the women April 15th is when I'm in Cork
Ireland and
and I mean the UK starting the 20th so
you want to join that last leg of the
tour brah
really door I really do what do what are
the dates shooting Sweden got them
Goldenberg Gothenburg Gothenburg yeah
yeah that would be April 27th and then I
have the 28th off geez what if I'm gonna
have any fun the 29th I'm an answer damn
yeah yeah and we should spend a little
time in Amsterdam well if you're gonna
roadog it with me and then the 30th I'm
in Norway Oslo is there any way to get
an extra day in Amsterdam and then
Stockholm Sweden is May so wait there in
Amsterdam for one day
um there's spread it out no no no no
look at the girls just sitting there and
now I'm an SM for two days
yeah we need three days in Amsterdam
well that's a little long but it's not
trust me hey trust me
party like I do two days bro we're gonna
get to that part of live we're gonna get
something we're not gonna make the tour
do you need the girls in the girls do it
yeah that's what you walk by that's what
you walk by and I yet stone cold cash in
my pocket for the dick jokes I tell and
I gotta level this oh you're not you and
Amsterdam I think I make a prediction
you're not gonna be you're not gonna
stand out as a big guy biggest tallest
people in the world are there and you
know i'ma stand out as an awesome guy so
I'm gonna have fun out there look at all
the drugs okay so you know what you guys
do it without me then and we won't shoot
up together fine [ __ ] it we would have
so much fun there dude it'll be a blast
I know the world's catching up to
Amsterdam make prostitution illegal
because it's [ __ ] a lot and then
regulate it to the dollar with myself
you're seeing the old Willy Wonka the
fat kid who Kiska has to drink the
chocolate yeah that's that's me answer
damn that's you I have to try the ladies
of the night Brendan stop talking that
way first now you're right dude we're
public and I have to try the drugs you
have to try the drugs I do all the drugs
no you're gonna hurt your heart's gonna
stop but it's gonna be great
now
go go to now go to the next picture of
him of him
let me see is Instagram fifty shades of
brown brown that's so [ __ ] cute
looking was he was he upset or he's open
not at all he was a little concerned
because he's like why are there nice and
stuff out but he was good he's so cute
Amy he's so cute like what are your
comic dinosaur Dyson or how cute is that
I've Dyson the base the north god it's
cute Dyson on alright go to the next one
all right that's pics hometown dude it's
your boy bear taking those pictures to
Houston I'm so grateful for you guys get
and play this it's like seven people are
gonna show that look look well all the
slowly alcoholic holdout Brian but look
at the alcoholic how many whiskey's did
yes because you know what you got a
little problem you have a problem you
got a little problem huh yeah you tell
me cuz you drank some serious whiskey
there right my boy that Drake come on
don't sound just kid now don't say that
but you do you don't be that way don't
start comparing yourselves in the
Beatles of drink I'll get super angry
wait so no so my boy whiskey Pete who's
the head member of the whiskey club in
Houston so oh I tried Pappy been think
oh well and and if we just call it Pappy
wrinkles have to call it copy regs I got
in the front so I went pass me the Pappy
drinks and you don't Hey I'm 9 trust at
my whiskey that's your boy Steve at
scope I wants to give us a goddamn
tasting we gotta go there yeah tried it
though look at me not worth the looming
huh I've had better
yeah it's just there's the hype this
might be its it's rare happy vanna Pappy
that's your boy hey I just want that's
him
I want you to know something though and
I it's not me I don't want to be shitty
about this it's not me you got your
plantings I like plans hold on I go to
hold up he told me cuz I went dude what
was i drinking cuz that [ __ ] was amazing
and you know what he said it's Clanton's
rare he
said oh the one I gave you called
Blanton straight from the barrel not
available in the US of A and you drink
in 1970s Wild Turkey Jesus an EIN teen
36 old Schenley rye what do mean in 1936
though no 19 the year 1936 so it's from
1936 yes how about this one ready for
this a 1917 old log cabin God you should
have seen the BAM oh no he he but he had
this case and he said it's over a
hundred seven thousand dollars worth of
whiskey was like whoa my drink of 2011
Pappy Van Winkle 20 20 years old then
that that one not there that's that
delicious plans I'm home but that one
you love have this one this one you see
that with the one without the label
that's a Jack Daniels from straight from
the distillery they can't sell it's
called calf strength 160 proof Holy
Mother of God
so you drank yourself a lot of whiskey I
sampled a lot of those those real liked
that one that's the 1971 that's yeah
you're just paying for how old it is
it's not that it's not necessarily great
know that plan was the best we see I've
had all oh yeah so you had you had that
blink I like plans that's my go-to now
that that that you had the you head
straight from the cask and it's nice
it's smooth huh booth I also like the
Japanese whiskeys my boy Brian Cooley I
want you to try the Elisha 18 I want to
see what you think I'm down dude because
he sent me that and that's supposed to
be beautiful now now hold on so you're
so you have a drinking problem we know
this slightly how you put down you
probably drink six shots of whiskey
that's during the shows but you're a big
guy so you think I'll feel I feel like
I'm in fright Friday night coming up a
little little loaded your boy got loose
you got loose loose and you're on stage
no problem you're doing your thing
problem at all having fun I'm relaxed
yeah yeah I'm yep I woke up then one
minute the next morning like oh yeah
boys a little hungover I'm dehydrated in
the old brain missed a lot of cash in my
pocket uh I spent some money yeah now
does it make you impulsive because you
know you got some brain that's some
brain trauma
oh that's why I didn't tell you I start
doing nicotine oh yeah why not smoking
why might I look cool if I do it don't
smoke don't get yourself these habits at
36 you die hurt but I will drink can't
pick up I got a live so moking my buddy
Jerry started smoking now like God we
were like what are you doing is it you
ezel 48 like huh
you just start smoking in the yago well
you guys I used to smoke I missed it
every [ __ ] day the past 25 I'm not
I'm not gonna smoke but I'm sure I'll
then she get there but I'm gonna start
doing a nicotine patches and like gum
your brainy me tasks with me really good
dude look how cool he looks yeah man my
grandpa died from it yes did my grandma
look at Humphrey Bogart when he was 41
42 look at how old he is look they all
looked so much older back in from the
smokin oh yeah JFK smoke drinking
smoking that they never worked out you
know what they did though binge they
lived they live Bubba they [ __ ] out a
live brother you know I got to tell you
all this talk about health me you're a
crank are you living
are you living are you doing great [ __ ]
I hope that smoke looks cool I top your
Bogart one of the great smoke a little
uh devil's dandruff now a lot of fans
bring that Devils Devils dan I'm sorry
deviled lettuce okay not the damn
cracked now double digits crash cocaine
he got a fans yeah I [ __ ] up devil's
lettuce I'll smoke that that it's a
little weed a little weed and you smoke
with a little whiskey no I don't make
some I've never I've only made foreign
once Rogan I was doing Rogan his podcast
forever ago at the ice house
I was drinking whiskey which I'm not a
whisky drinker and I smoked some weed
and I got up and I was on stage I wrote
this this bit about saving a whale and a
crushed I bet it [ __ ] Russia or how
it did for I did very well know used to
smoke on stage is Jim Gaffney Jim
Gaffigan you smoke back you know I never
saw that would seem out death Larry yes
Larry always remember
oh I've comics used to [ __ ] you I saw
Denis Leary's at first I saw Denis
Leary's first show ever in New York City
in nineteen
90 UAV a monster he was he did something
called his first show was called I'm
gonna I'm gonna smoking I camera is I'm
gonna die someday or whatever at Lycia
it was incredible and it was a live
performance it's a one-man show
it wasn't even stand and said well
there's a one-man show and he was
smoking cigarettes and I was like hold
he booked you little [ __ ] cuz he's
coming they joked thief and stuff like
no he's not a joke speak and I mean well
no he did steal like a whole bit
dennis has trouble Dennis was that's it
was always gonna be successful then I
agree nobody works hard he did get in
trouble for stealing yeah but that was
all [ __ ] but I know that don't worry I
was around with that but but Dennis
Leary is undeniable and was always just
an amazing [ __ ] he's he's a great actor
he's a writer yet the Bill Hicks well
yeah if it was word for word but my
thing is with Dennis Larry like he'd be
sick to your point he'd be successful in
matter well no matter what that dude was
he's undeniable he's awesome
I know Dennis I mean I I've spent enough
time with you still alive yeah I I mean
Dennis is then and the people that do
know him think he's great too
dennis is a great guy he was a mom he's
a he's a dennis is also I think Boston
Irish you know what's his showing affect
the fire shilling yeah I was inspired
what was it called rescue me
great show he wrote that with no I think
no Longton no yeah then he had sex drugs
and rock and roll yeah he's uh he's
undeniable dude he's never Dennis wrote
that one one-man show that was so
[ __ ] good performed it before anybody
was doing that stuff I mean I was there
for at all
yeah I'm a fan yeah I'm a fan and I and
Jimmy Burke who trained him for years is
very close to Dennis all my friends they
trained with his personal trainer it's a
personal trainer well years
Dennis was also I mean he was he was
good he was Jerry McFadden very good
friends mean he does he do now he made I
just hangs out with his millions yeah
right on this kiss writing racism okay
cigarettes Dennis had kids very early
you know he had a sick child when he was
younger but he's about an elephant he's
a badass
I got nothing bad to say about that guy
oh he still
8'o he's still doing stand-up oh yeah oh
let's listen he's doing step he's at the
TD Garden Arena in Boston yeah that's
for the Celtics place yeah dude no no no
he's won the bass economy yeah he's
Denis Leary I'm just saying I'll see
after him I'm like younger than he is
yeah so like in the comedy circle I just
heard people out saying how Jack Bill
Hicks that was so what's up so those
people listen man if Dennis he'd be a
great guest on our show
I'd love I'd love to have a month yeah
he's just amazing I mean I I and by the
way I looked into that Bill Hicks thing
I was there for it I mean I was doing it
I I just don't buy it
there was Bill Hicks had a huge he had a
huge effect and influence on people a
lot of so much yeah so were you so what
happens is you yeah it rubs off your a
few of my best friends are no cure for
cancer my best friends are you
Tooley it like a lot of my mannerisms a
ton of mine are yours right yeah our
lingo yeah the way I we all you know the
way I flow environment fine how people
see me do someone stays like do that's
so calendar 5% whatever I think was my
mentor but what I do in I do Jay and I
do Jimmy Burke you know like you know
there's so much of what I was doing was
you know doing dim Jimmy I was like when
I was younger because he was older and
he was New York and I was like [ __ ] you
know that stuff like I'm not hearing a
peep out of him yet
that's Jimmy yeah you know that stuff
Baba that's Jimmy all that stuff is
closed guys those guys were older than
me from New York Jimmy I come hide but I
stole that [ __ ] and then now you know
it's what we do language is passed down
something accents exact accents come
from from listening to your older of
yours are they going to be like a frat
sense right so you admire me can on your
[ __ ] knees hey man huh sorry how do
you start what'd you do this weekend
dude hey I did hey if you do not wear
those gucci boots on wednesday when our
friend mark norm is here okay I will I'm
gonna I'm gonna slap you around Bobby
Lee wants to do our podcast again - I
love luckily we'll talk to him about his
father passed away Oh Dan and he showed
me in the most amazing picture of his
dad I've ever seen dude he goes you want
to see something disturbing and
me his mother when his father died right
the minute his father died he said his
mother said please take a picture and
Bobby took a picture of his mother
crying over it because she wanted one
last image of and he'll tell the story
yeah let me you're telling them no but
yeah but but dude this is a woman who'd
been with this man for 60 years and you
see her crying you see it Bobby's
brother over his father and this is a
man who was loved and was obviously a
great father cuz Bobby you know and his
brother and and this is a man who did
his job he died at 81 and it was one I
who I can't wait to see his iconic
picture things I well I kept staring at
I thought you and say he caught like the
spirit well he may as well have because
she's crying over this man she's been
with for sixty years and it was heavy I
was like hey Bobby in your grief you
just took like a picture that I would
put on my [ __ ] wall just to
interested in his dead it encapsulates
humanity it encapsulates everything we
stay alive Bobby post it nobody she
personal forehead and stuff it's too
personal but I mean he like he thought I
was gonna make a joke and I was like I
was too blown away by the picture so
yeah we'll get him on we'll get him on I
love Bobby so much so we got our boy
mark Normand Brogan [ __ ] loved said
that guy's just a great guy mark yeah
yeah another another real comic New York
College real comic yeah Eamonn Andrews
Schultz yeah the next yes
Biggie's the big wait what we talking
about before that are you obviously oh
this weekend I did two hours total of
comedy and Saturday I did a full two
hours of comedy I was on stage for four
sets last night I did two sets oh well
I've been doing sets yeah I saw you
grind I see the yeah cuz I'm writing and
I'm the oldest at 52 maybe some best
shot sets in my life lately
no yeah because I'm but this is what's
great about stand-up you want but you're
also one of the best thank you better
but that's all the lineup I think
because they went Bob Lee Bobby Lee than
you yeah that's when you know you're it
was Bobby Lee along then I was Ali Wong
then I'm a Sebastian Maniscalco it's not
a bad it's not a bad [ __ ]
Jesus lineup it's not a bad line up I
thought to myself these [ __ ]
are getting some some good [ __ ] it was
good comedy store has never been better
Laugh Factory improv and do I did every
one of those clubs um was I ain't tell
you hmm
I'm enjoying stand-up there's a fire
outside of some sort going home this
week dude you're gonna Jennifer doing
the Denver I'm going to Tampa this
weekend in Tampa this way yeah Friday
said well though yeah I love I love you
boys city I love that old theater
yes are you excited about Denver you get
a little nervous Gillis anxiety almost
things I could it's overwhelming cuz
everybody you know is there and I like
to economy for people I know
yeah we're didn't it Russy clubs we
could see club you great my brothers
come I'll see her new [ __ ] dude have you
seen Jay go to Jason's getting post a
picture with his titties out why yeah
his tits are out
I don't know what to Singapore and his
tits are all over the place what da [ __ ]
is going on here
dick you see he's a big boy boys like a
Snickers he's got he's got a I didn't
know his he's a devil head he has a
devil head now what do you mean devil
head it's weight Tanner which is weird
he hasn't been his eyes look he looks he
looks like it's not so neat giotto
shopped his head he looks like a
torturer waiting for you to get to her
guys Wow shark eyes dog smiles and he's
a barrel-chested [ __ ] man he's strong
though I knew he goes he goes he said he
never talks about being strong but I
said I mean why are you how much can you
dead live can you tell him cuz he's
talking about strong you are and he goes
he goes you couldn't eat we were sitting
there eating it if you put 500 pounds
down right now I'll get up and do it
right now Jesus Christ he's so mad he's
so serious because I didn't matter right
now
Jesus you're really strong which one it
was a shoulder no he's had that he's
tatted up the the the lucky whatever we
commercial horseshoe Jen and I have we
as a hair grows like Austin Powers
he's got awesome powers his chest hair
the shadows in this world it's got his
nips he's thick though huh
he's a thick now one trap was higher
than the other it is I think still he's
always at a computer like this yeah he's
all I wanna go [ __ ] get him out of
there man
we're close really close yep want to
bring on full times he stopped what say
he's got a Houston now he is that
Houston right now what do you mean he's
living Jay has to fly to Houston every
Monday and flies home every Friday I
didn't know that for work I want Jay
he said he's sometimes like when we're
on the road if it's like a Thursday he
has to do the meetings you know it's
like two-hour meeting and I'll sit with
him he puts it on speaker I'm like this
is a complete waste of [ __ ] time
so another's waste of resources and time
so you could have him on the road full
time with you you guys together mm-hmm
with that road schedule while I wrote
schedule I can and then also you know
you can run all the help with CBD and
cats helped me a ton - so you're CBD you
got the coffee you know got a bunch of
other stuff that me and Jay just bought
our first property in Arizona together
yeah you did
so there's a bunch of stuff wait I don't
want you buying Arizona Scottsdale why'd
you buy just a property house already
air B&B it nice that's great there's a
ton of stuff he could do now he's gonna
have to get hit the is tan a little more
diverse well we got out we got it we got
to create a uniform tan don't just put
your head in a some Sunday don't put
just your head in a sunjai he's at
Singapore's nuts look at the other
pictures your is amazing either what
have you been there yes
Singapore is amazing lifts up [ __ ]
loads write them down without Alya yeah
Alaa Thea right I am watching
I am bi happier i anthony i anthe
i anthe i ant I know that I knew that
it's a black girls they have eautiful
auntie she's a girl rock those names
gorgeous 25% Japanese she is yes with
curves for days all due respect full
blown did they get a universal
I don't know what thing some dork this
has been Singapore though yeah hmm yeah
friends cuz that's the coolest thing
ever
yeah look at the sink were looks insane
yeah it does
what do you do there though they will
they go to the races they love the races
J's girls more into the races than he is
really yeah they love little shirts you
don't wear that without a psycho fan
look at a shirt look at Jase [ __ ]
smile know what's going on with the
smile let's call Jay right now I want to
have it I want to he's on a plane oh yes
he lands in LA at 9:00 he does but then
he flies to Denver
I'll see him Thursday in Denver you
wanna have dinner this week or no you
and me why don't we go to Felix tonight
what me he late no he laying straight to
Denver oh I'll see him in Denver on
Thursday oh I got you okay you should
say a day have you been have you been
Felix yet dude have you been off
Felix yet uh and then I sent Rogan there
on Saturday they love it talk to him
about it
Oh RB took a breather no I took a break
to Wally's oh it's really dude me and aa
B and some friends went to this like
Soho House of Austin oh right you were
announced oh man it was fun was it oh
this place do you know so house here
yeah yeah it's all pretend just like the
worst thing in Hollywood yes there it's
like a private club with their food and
they have great whiskey's and hookah I
was smoking whoo God Wow I'd like to go
there man I ain't [ __ ] living sniped
a little ketamine ha ha ha
Brendan you can't do Special K jack is
that what it is yeah ketamine that's a
horse tranquilizer
did you do ketamine you can't admit
these things on my podcast
what's wrong with it you're a drug it is
Teta me it's a horse tranquilizer look
up ketamine there pass it around like is
[ __ ] for real vicks vapor spray dude
like look at how am I to know
everybody's ear off ketamine you want to
look at the wiki yeah let me read it
what I need to know about it's a
medication mainly is starting and
maintaining anesthesia trance-like state
well yeah relieve sedation ah my foot
didn't hurt at all
other uses include for chronic pain
sedation or intensive K and their care
and depression I want to hug everybody
okay well I got real lovey-dovey on this
you snort it
you're surpassing about what is it it's
special K went love the cereal let me
try that thank you you are you like your
drugs dude I'm getting there I'm living
well you're very successful I'm living
bro do drugs you're a bad influence dude
bloody or cloudy P that's good for you
in have that trouble peeing or
definitely so much halo are blush lips
blonde okay lips could ingest man I
guess if you do a lot lower your vision
yeah a little bit shortness of breath
confusion convulsions good problems with
swallowing this fast slow irregular
heartbeat HS hives you're too big to be
doing this [ __ ] is if you're doing all
the time at one time use the nice state
salad I think I'll just say I would not
have done Special K see we see that's a
problem we call it Special K that sounds
a little risky yeah call it ketamine
yeah can I mean does sound like a
protein says like a protein powder how's
it gonna mean oh ass well it rhymes with
creatine yes and then also I take kratom
so Kratos until take kratom do i you're
a drug addict dude I didn't know any of
this dammit you're one of those guys
that is very effective and still you
just grind it's fine well it's like
Rogan who smokes weed and these more
intense than ever it's not like weed
mellow Joe out it's just he built an
empire ketamine is the medication side
effects include confusion no I didn't
have any of that this is so great well I
didn't know I did a real drug I had no
clue yesterday that's a bar you know
we're passing it on no you thought it
was like some cool lasers hookah you
thought I was like oh my nose is stuffy
I'll try that
you did you did the gage rug - you know
special case the gave drug y know gave
drugs Molly no sir it's also special K
is done in the gay community why because
it relaxes you and it relaxes your boot
your body your booty hole well yeah your
as well you're a lot more receptive you
know how you start but you know you
start fishes usually hall i love i was
pretty relaxed yeah and you know your
starfish is usually all ten-hut and
tight and all anal oh well your starfish
stops being so it's happy hour banal
that's happy in case okay relax
so you got you got a happy hour all of a
sudden your rumpy-pumpy feels like it's
happy hour all the time because usually
happy hours just like a couple hours
after work right now it's happy hour all
night long and yeah how many times have
i told you dude that you're the bottom
every single time and a guy like me i
might be skinny I made it rawhide and
cable she's got a dick gun yeah I got a
dick on me and I'm older and I'm
dominant and you're trying to pour into
the south
Dom and then oh yeah and we've been
friends a long time but you're all sniff
he sniffed up with the Academy didn't
know it laughs relax was some whiskey
and we're in the bathroom and often you
hear and you're like what you doing I go
I drew the bolt
I drew the bolt you and me and I'm like
hey I love you and you go huh I love you
tall dude on ketamine I would have said
I love that girl is that what's that
spot on the wall and you're like what
spot I'm like yeah you were peeing
already since mr. hands you know cat
space know if you like new face looks
like she's she looks like she smells
something bad cuz she bout so much you
know what in so my and I'm like keep
keep keep your eyes on that spot it have
to be like mr. hands
yeah you better your move fast yeah cuz
you're gonna be like I didn't I say I
started this tie saying we're starting
on Monday with our hair did you yeah
so you hear me go and you go
dude I'm more baffled at ketamine as a
serious drug yeah dude it's the gay drug
I see I think that's in your circle I
don't think so that's okay cocaine it
sir Special K is as cocaine flushes you
out you're clean pie at gay at gay raves
engage communities but ketamine is
well-known it's a well-known yeah it's
it's well-known a lot of gay men are
very familiar with Special K a lot of
the a lot of these the party boys I
should say votes I'm sorry you call it
gay drug I'm just saying that it's it's
not there's a reason it's used in in the
gay sir I did feel very relaxed I'll
give you that yeah now do you feel you
could get an erection on it yeah see you
don't think about now it opens things up
in the back flop that sloppy yeah you
start people open floppy in the black
sloppy no no it's the out of the way oh
yeah loo sloppy in the front the loose
in the back not be in the front and open
in the back hey not be in the front and
open in the back Special K is your best
friend yeah the shop is closed in front
but we'll take deliveries through the
back yeah that's right
sorry we're we're closing the front but
there's a secret secret entrance in the
back password your drug and the password
is awesome hmmm what was like is the
sphincter yeah days I would have said
they said the most popular gay drug is
poppers
what's a what operator this right here
alcohol night charts that are inhaled
and it relaxes the sphincter muscles
isn't that special k2 no don't you don't
lump all that in [ __ ]
find out what pop what's in poppers I'm
gonna tell you right now what's a popper
a there's a Wikipedia right there when
you click on poppers Jim we were looking
at it not poppers really yeah it's a
slang term broadly is the chemical class
called alkaline nitrates that are
inhaled practical purposes Chris blood
for the man crease is higher rush for
sexual encounters I ain't touching that
hold on poppers were part of a club
culture
the disco era but isn't what I want to
know it's a vegetable Special K for gay
parties hold on you can type anything
well i sperm at reggae parties you know
look it let me see what's in let me see
what's in the bottle click a Kennedy
yeah anyone else ever done it no
champion has never ketamine I know
people that did do it don't it they love
it I don't think there are two girls and
they both said that they were just like
really gone gone yeah like they're out
of like gone with another dude no they
were with each other yeah I know a
missionary copper's yeah I'm interested
in poppers now now you don't want
poppers dude that's for kids hold on as
an aesthetic alternative to PC Pete do
you live in bro it's good to me no it's
methylamine oh it's hydrochloride it's
similar to poppers I'm gonna say Kimmy
is all stone especially if a second
effect as anesthesia oh that's okay it
blocks pain signals yeah yeah I did feel
good dude hey how was your fight I did
this I did this on a Thursday night no
[ __ ] given what do you think I'm gonna
do in Amsterdam dude why not coming back
well people are listening to this in
Amsterdam and you're gonna have I got a
story for you about a stirrer damn yeah
yeah I had a girlfriend who went there
oh no what happened she was a naughty
girl she was a [ __ ] naughty girl and
I loved her yeah I lived with her okay
and she was hanging out with a guy okay
and there was an older gentleman tall he
was dressed in she said he looked like a
Buccaneer he was dressed in like kind of
knickers with boots he had a stunt he
had a monocle a good not a monocle but
he had a a watch chain with a watch and
he was really well dressed and he had a
cane but he didn't have a limp
and he was kind of like this he had a
top hat like a [ __ ] magician but
handsome and older and she goes it
became very clear that he was sort of
the the the Fagin esque leader of this
bar like everyone knew him and he had
money and then I found that that he had
a legendary [ __ ] his [ __ ] was enormous
that that word around town or she told
and she said no no his friend said heard
the guy she was kind of [ __ ] was
friends with him and she realized that
he was she was kind of being presented
to him uh-huh
and I said as I swallowed it and I was
like what happened next and she said I'm
not turned on well I was very interested
in how big his coffee turns out let's
figure it out he said to her she said I
hear you have a huge [ __ ] he said well
there's only one way to find out and
apparently she sucked them yes in the
bar no on the on the veranda of the bar
outside yes and then what she did her
job yeah and then and then mobile on her
blanket side yep and he brought her back
inside and they had drinks and laughed
and then she went home with the GI dude
yeah did the other dude you know of
course he said of course he did sperm al
yeah he presented her too but after
you've been drinking whiskey all my fun
and stuff kills and right so he was she
presented and she was a champ she was
down for the [ __ ] adventure what
happened she's a badass
she's still alive she's of course she's
still alive she's doing great
is she yeah I know her no she's one of
the best she's one she's she hold on it
sounds like the best yeah yeah the
outlaw the I used to call her the outlaw
who she was a traveler a gypsy out one
of the best one of the best and that was
your girlfriend though she was she was
somebody I loved she was hot yep yeah
I've had some yes yeah yeah yeah my
girlfriend yeah
yeah we had been over we had an over but
by the way you know me oh hey like I
feel like if I was living with her and
still her and she told me that story we
welcome her back and still it would have
been appear there would have been a bad
punishment oh yeah
got it we got to pay the piper now I've
been into the piper I'm gonna need
dimensions I'm gonna need everything I'm
gonna need diagrams but you should come
out here I love you more I love you more
by the way my two balls might might love
you more that you've got that sense of
it listen I want my quarterback through
a few interceptions yeah I'm saying I
mean right I'm not that possessive I'm a
[ __ ] sexual communist I share sorry
all right now I'm not mad at you got
some along the same line we're having
this is honest Monday it's been on
Monday hottest Monday very intense thing
one of my favorite podcast so far I wish
we could find that girl wish I knew what
she looked like
I'm impressed that six years on we're
still doing the damn thing is level
today man still doing the damn thing of
it well you know and no sign well you
know dude we're dogs aren't we like I'm
your dog yeah and you know got a little
heated this weekend over some [ __ ] I
heard and yeah yeah I just get a little
angry and what's what well what we say
what we say at the end of the day is you
get more successful what really matters
is your friends is the people that are
there for you no matter what
that should I think that's why this
shows held up yeah there's there was it
did get a little dicey there remember
when like we'd switch studios than you
were shooting yeah it was gin us
Cortelyou got it yeah but it doesn't
matter at the end of the day this is the
mothership and we do our thing Golden
Goose really is the mothership Golden
Goose are these old things
I'm not giving those shoes where'd you
get those I don't know oh yes I got them
yesterday I'm very happy with those
shoes and new golden gooses how could I
have to wear special insoles but I need
to get custom one how are you how was
your plantar fasciitis scale one to ten
seven oh that's bad we need to go get
some stem cells to see what's up I need
stem cells for many reasons my sister
Christie our girl yeah Chris shout-out
to her but also everyone tells me just
get custard
in souls and the make them go away then
went dude I've done it so many people in
Houston Tennessee I've done everything
just get custom installs and it's gonna
go away in week really and everybody
like I had a foot doctor come out to me
go
gotta get customer something really goes
I know everyone tells you I sit I'd be
Pro I'm Tony you have that and three
weeks a foot doctor he's a diet he's a
straight up okay so he knows yeah so so
is that what you do then you you do I
need to do how what our custom insults
you dig hold it they got mold your foot
and then make them they're not you have
that I worth that I've dr. Scholl's in
right now so it's worth it but I want to
do that I want to get customer you don't
need that but but why wouldn't I get
them you don't have problems so what
with your foot it's probably good for
your foot anyway I mean think you know
I'm saying like I want custom insoles
the best guess why wouldn't I have them
see that's that's he I need someone well
it when is where are you going cuz I
want to go and I need to farm hoping
someone hears this in PM's me in LA to
get it done hey I need to do - I want to
come oof plantar fascial it's a
[ __ ] oh it's a mother if I get
up every morning I kid laughs at me dude
I can't walk I can't walk in the morning
cuz my feet in my hand when I get my
achilles are I walk like I have wood
wooden feet for the first 30 seconds
philia was good at current events man
wait cat what'd you do this weekend mmm
I went to the comedy store and who was
up it was I feel happened to be there it
was I was there Joey Diaz on Wednesday
night uh yeah I saw you too thin it I
thought you said you weren't there Oh
once it was the one that I didn't have
begun Joey Diaz you know are I know I
was in the main room oh dude don't go
without me and Brian who'd you bring I
brought it was my boyfriend and then my
two friends from college
mmm yeah just means you okay what'd you
do - I did a few stuff like I went to a
few stuff a few stuff few things to
double it to double a plurality sorry
about that Friday I went to cream
barbecue later now a standard yeah and
then who'd you
with my friend Joey and my friend Judy
never heard and Judy threw up it's
because what happened she she's such a
lightweight she only had a few shots of
soju and it was enough for her to toe
yack soju sake sake yes this is Lissa
it's Korean vodka okay
yeah okay stands when she threw up
anything for you couldn't finish our
food because it smelled like [ __ ] well I
mean she was pretty much being carried
out we had no idea she was throwing up
in the machine was blacked out yeah from
like four shots of soju okay
so then we just had them cook the food
on the plate or the grill and then take
it to go ahead what a buzz I was a
bummer I gotta eat what a buzzkill
though yeah it is and then probably
don't be her friend
I recorded a richard marx cover who's
Richard dude remarks hey Dave Matthews
or bust
I keep posting I got a huge well my
friends a huge Dave massive Matthews fan
slave he's a Dave slave and he was
telling me a different song so I'm
looking into ass the show still when you
post you want to see it really yeah we
loved it yeah people work I feel like
it's gonna be a chin and play the guitar
there's no [ __ ] and I was like ask a
Jewish man use hold on here and there's
a story behind this too
there's my comment
[Music]
there's any different camera
that's all I got
humates 10-7
it's never great voice and thank you
Brian how about Buster play can you sing
Andy Griggs fees more great choice - I
love that song no I'm all set on love
songs out of here bro
I want to change the station to
something else give me a different genre
bro this is different you have a great
voice thank you boys to men it all
sounds like boys are meant to be perfect
this is always dementia
so this song I posted this on Friday
night and I didn't actually tag Richard
Marx his account on it I just did a
hashtag with his name and turns out he
actually saw it and liked it oh here's
my question
here's my question himself Mike was
because here's my question when are we
gonna see some original music
I have original music Oh interesting
- a few eventually no that sounds like
that sounds like procrastination you got
to do the wrens damn shop School of Life
just do it just do it yeah did you want
some you guys did just keep telling me
out there this is a lot easier though
with the time I have right now I know
well the time the worst the worst thing
I could ever hope the worst thing you
could say that [ __ ] why I mean this is
every time I talk to people and they're
like would you have any advice I need to
hide all that I know but I gotta say a
lot today when they say you know like
well it's easy I've been busy right now
I go I I can't talk to you about this
then I don't I don't care about easy and
it's never easy to be original that's
just fun this is fun by the way I'm
working out every single day because of
what you said good every single day so
why don't we start taking ourselves
seriously as an artist and start writing
original songs all posts of original in
like two weeks
mmm no that sounds like I'm gonna quit
smoking next year do a Dave Matthews and
then do you see I have to learn Dave
Matthews Dave Matthews don't you be
their own - agent Dave Matthews exactly
yeah why don't you do that and write a
song that surprises and shocks you I
know
yeah maybe call my original expression
damn it rap a little all right I know
that responsibility never goes away
mines getting so deep with the stuff
yeah I get deepest [ __ ] and my voice
gets all kind of soda oh wait why did
you dick hard
oh my god all right what are you asking
here we go good luck that original sound
thanks man
so a mother of a 17 year old kid in
Washington turn in her kid after reading
in his journal that he was planning to
do a mass shooting at his school Jesus
Christ and for that mom got to do that
good for that mom good snoopy mom
reading her kids journal worth it worth
it I just saved lives
Oh
please so what they do he is currently
detained out of juvenile center right
now yeah yeah I must be was for a mom to
do that's what she's saying apparently
she was very emotional when she did it
but she was felt like there was a
responsibility to others oh yeah good
for her yeah that's a that's a heroic
Yvonne armed with that kid like what do
you do with him I guess at that age like
you're so spontaneous you think the
whole world's caught up in this loser
and you know your brain is developing
Jekyll I'm saying so you're pretty
spontaneous and you're not really
thinking he may like history we have
industry of the little time may have a
history of depression may have a history
of drug use may have a history of
antidepressants and things like that
which we know a lot of these kids are on
SS are that all we know is he's gonna
show up to school to see if he had any
issues or anything
it didn't say whether he had any
specific issues but he did want to do it
on the same day as the Columbine
anniversary haha damn it was very
methodical
Wow yeah that sounds like he was very
serious about killing he must know his
research calm I was a long time ago so
it was a major school shooting I was in
dude I was it I'll never forget I was in
miss Bennet's math class my freshman
year and our school get was on lockdown
it was so scary and then there was like
a list depressing oh dude well he was
the first one I remember I should answer
because he did my TV show my pilot
wasn't picked up according to legend
because of it because Rupert Murdoch saw
me with a gun
he owned Fox at the time and saw me with
a gun and I wish I had a shooting range
in my basement and Breckin Meyer is
walking as I'm loading it and and he
goes no no no no sorry and that was that
dude Miss Bennet she put on TV we went
on shutdown and then I remember like the
weeks after that there was someone made
a list some morons made a list of other
schools that are going to be shot up and
our schools on that list so we get large
schools shutdown we'd have school for
like two or three days after that weird
yeah well no it was such a crazy and
then you can aware you can aware a black
jack
well because they watched basketball
Diaries and the Leonardo DiCaprio with
the trench coat you know the trench coat
long ago that's what it was or and in
his dream he pulls out a gun and shoots
his teacher and everybody it was so
scared the one kid and Dylan Klebold one
of them was a sadistic sociopath he was
tortured animals when he had a history
of this terrible human being found and
found this one kid who was terribly
depressed and kind of manipulated him
what else yet okay before I show you
which state there is one state here in
the US that has passed a law making it
illegal to send unsolicited nude photos
can you guys so toes it's specifically
geared towards like unsolicited dick
pics but what state do you guys think it
is Utah
I'd say it's uh it's one of two it's
either a very conservative state like
Texas or or it's like a really liberal
state like Massachusetts it's Texas
Texas just passed along but I just saw a
Texas law just passed this law making it
illegal to send unsolicited nude photos
to people so they gotta wanna order to
send them I think it's because ya get so
many of these pictures do you get a lot
of them cut yes so [ __ ] my dick pic
yeah when you when my Instagram first
came out I had to block and delete so
many people on the show at the time yeah
okay I just do so many and now it's
every now and then I'll get a random one
but I just stop blocking I stopped
looking through my DMS I can't
is that bad oh yes it's they started to
get a little more creative not even
created one a little more like proud
about it cuz before it was just like the
dick and then became like the dick and
the body now it's straight up just like
face and everything god damn yeah check
out there's that there my my wife is
laughing
SDM ma you know that chatroulette have
you seen that website she goes watch
this Oh
letting go just go to it and just huh
watch this go to chat read calm wait it
well I get another no I don't think so
chatroulette let me go on a different
browser again what is it for right so
it's where people can like yes now it's
random people how many guys Archer
cannot hurt its trouble look at how many
guys are jerking off on this thing I was
laughing notion is that you are on a
webcam with another person a random
person and you just kind of meet new
people but a lot of people all you'll
see youse guys jacking off
that's all usually all you see it's just
skip over people but you may skip your
start don't show your face turn the
light on Rohit you turn the light out of
the light I just put a hood on put your
hood on put your eyes
that's good what do you mean we don't
have to actually open it up yeah yeah
bro you're good dude just let me see
your face hey who is that I don't notice
what background yeah there you go okay
you look like the Unabomber yes and your
and hide that Mike come on can you zoom
in
how come we can't see anything oh you
look awesome there now go you'll see
something I just start yeah old people
gonna think you want it dude
did you look so suspect almost come
closer got it got it thanks processing
watch I don't know I've never - stay
right there stay right next endo partner
do you ever hear someone jacking off
right now we might watch much I want
some
like a man looking for a friend what's
happening oh don't show us t-shirt you
won't see this how do you click the next
replicator laughing what's up girl
God you can't not know girls don't sure
these girls are showing on TV video yeah
she was pretty yeah your turn right she
was like oh oh oh what's this guy doing
don't don't talk because they can hear
us
oh they can hear me yes oh they're
smoking we do what's up girls you know
surprise what's up girl
hello you smoking that ganja in the back
there young man
oh I don't know what I'm doing I know
keep let them do something before I no
let's wait till we get the guys Jack and
this is great there's this website and
there's another one Oh Michael is
well-known for this week's you want to
get on here cannot connect connect in so
just Scrolls do how many people how many
people aren't here what's up bro these
guys are changing girls oh they don't
want you to watch girls they're scooter
yeah I mean look at what he's doing live
podcast oh yeah you wanna jump on this
rock us yeah yeah yeah okay what this
guy's jacket
this guy's jackin that guy was Jack and
dude oh it's over go oh oh wait wait
yeah cover yeah yeah give her sunglasses
Oh give her sunglasses oh my god like oh
oh well catskil no yes no what's up doc
can they hear me Jesus go to the next
one I can't look at his face I'm
freaking out we're doing something bad
keep going keep going keep going am I
just gonna keep on going next until we
find something we know yeah we don't use
[ __ ] with games privacy oh there we go
yeah
what dude would take him here you can
hear us
I don't know how to use that thing where
the mic be can you see how many guys are
just waiting a jacket oh yeah there's a
lot of Jackson that's ago the neck
that's oh no oh he's poking his head out
poking his head out to catch the dorable
tool I know these guys gonna look I
guess I guess I guess the hardest thing
they've ever had on their anything
oh I get them off get off her dick on us
all right get a good dick on dude you
know what actually makes a better
toothbrush do you have any idea I just
know it takes a long time to brush my
teeth if not god why use poor bristle
yeah whatever I can do to keep my teeth
clean I just wish there was a faster
easier where it kind of a one step
process yeah that's like whip was
created by dentists and a product
designers to focus on what actually
matters for your oral health oh this is
a thing where you put in your mouth two
minutes thirty second pulses the
vibration sure isn't building primer
gentle brushing for the dentist's
recommendation of two minutes with
thirty second pulses so you know you're
doing it right I can tell more gets in
man you know more guesses or kids to if
you got kids like my kids don't brush
properly but you they can just bite onto
this thing and it just go just get
actually uses this every night these
really make life healthier get your
teeth right [ __ ] starts at just $25 you
get your first refill free at get quip
dot-com slash fighter if there's a
simple way to support the firing the kid
and to have a clean grill man start
looking better
brushing better but you have to get quip
calm slash a fighter it's about time
though and on time they came up with a
technology like this get your grill
clean get wick quip comm slash fighter
that's get to you IP calm slash fighter
so I just ate this is where I get all my
meat from butcher oh I know I'm a pest
you cannot do you mind if I use your
grill can I use your grill why sure cuz
I wanna put my meat on it
yeah yeah put my butchers behind so the
best meat and I'm not kidding the best
pork the best beef the best everything I
have butcher box
fridge right now actually my freezer and
my fridge I made burgers yesterday
because I had a pool like thing with all
the kids I'm telling you right now it's
the best meat in the world butcher box
it's out the steaks the pork it's great
percent grass-fed finished beef free
range organic chicken
yep okay why not see em work we all it's
all meat the way it was not crazy
expensive easier now no not crazy they
send it to you so I've been up I've been
me and Rogan have been customers of this
company for probably I don't know since
they started years since I started up
new years literally forever and they
they you get a box of meat every month
butcher box ships a curated selection of
high quality meat right to your crib
right to your crib butcher box is a
no-brainer ship right to your there if
they can Oh put your box the most
affordable and convenient way to get
healthy humanely raised meat in your
mouth and it's a it's up to nine or
eleven pounds of meat and that for
lottery bro 24 individual meal I get the
meat sweats right now right now right
now you've sealed it sits it you'd never
believe it was frozen want you no way
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones and right now butcher box
is offering the final kid listeners
new members ground beef for life I
forsaken that I was like what ground
beef for life that's 2 pounds of ground
beef in every box for the life of their
subscription plus $20 up their first box
geez that's I'm literally going home to
have their hamburgers music the beef
just go to butcher box.com slash fighter
enter promo code fighter at checkout
that's butcher box comm slash fighter or
enter promo code fighter at checkout put
your meat on your grill put you me on
your grill it's delicious can't put my
meat on your grill no I don't know what
that means I don't feel comfortable with
that thank you so much it's grass-fed no
I don't know though because now grill is
in other words so in theirs let me put
my grass-fed meat on your grill ok but
if you don't if you mean something else
I'm gonna be super mad what do you got
transitioning just from that to this
yeah we got was Jack Jack and heart I've
never heard of that you just get on it
just in hopes to find Thor you know
where you're gonna be most here Knights
all right now how did you know about
that dude how did you know about it
because my wife was laughing cuz her
friends like look at these [ __ ]
perverts I caught on and we were
watching it was like oh my god back then
it was one jerk one dick after another
he's like let me taste them I'm not
buying it Florida girl 6 arrested for
battery by school resource officer for
temper tantrum yes so a six year old
girl kicked a teacher who held her by
the wrist I guess she was acting out the
teacher was trying to get control of her
and reprimand her but what ended up
happening was the little girl started to
have a temper tantrum and kicked the
teacher a police officer who works with
the school then took it upon himself to
actually arrest her or police officers a
[ __ ] idiot
and he did it without apparently there's
protocol that if there's anyone below
the age of 12 you have to go to your
supervisor and then approve of the
arrest before you can actually do it and
this guy sits and for he was clean no
print and had her mugshot taken you
[ __ ] dummy he went through that
entire process dumb and by the time her
grandmother came and found out what was
happening she
is horrified to find out that her
granddaughter was being being
fingerprinted I would have lost my
[ __ ] mind I would have lost my mind
and so and that's just one dumb cop
yeah I'm guaranteed all his cop friends
make fun of him right now
and I guarantee he's getting roasted he
did another boy but that same day oh
really so he did it to two kids under
the age so he's obviously probably a
little bit different they put him to
protect them yeah he's kind of he's the
flowery he's obviously a complete some
people are just dumb dumb so yes in case
of a dumb dumb promise he's got a badge
and a gun so we might want to take his
badge and gun away and have him do
something like I don't know get people's
lockers ready at the station or
something that's not unique cops have a
tough job and it requires something on
us this job yeah it's no joke and you
don't want a guy like that giving cops a
bad name exactly have some troubles he's
being under he's in investigation right
now for that so it's probably five
Instagram is now restricting people
under the age of 18 from seeing products
that promote like the flat tummy T's the
like body enhancement stuff yeah like
summer basically anything that Kim
Kardashian and any IG model promote like
they basically can't see it unless you
are listed as somebody over the age of
17 well you know can I do that that
matters I'm not mad at but it's exactly
how it prom of kids was gonna lie on the
edge thing we were signing up they have
multiple accounts yeah but I like it I
like that it's kind of moving that way I
liked it that at least young kids aren't
having it under 18 will soon be blocked
from seeing post promoting certain
cosmetic surgery and diet products
there's Kim sucking on a rancher yeah I
get it I get that well that was fast
this Kim Kim Kardashian flat tummy shake
post from juniors now only it would be
logged into um listen over 18 it's not a
bad I mean it's flat I don't like
censorship but I don't really mind this
later
she need I don't mind it at all it's
Italy it's step in the right direction
yeah it's not gonna stop it but but at
least Instagram is doing their eyes they
realize like the negativity from
Jonathan heights work which is like
Queens young girls their anxiety levels
are so high
everyone's well it gets suicide
depressing yeah all me it's really
really laughing I get what nothing he
said tweens no no I'm just think of
something stupid
they got jack enough it's kind of burned
into my mind now yeah you're a big dick
not a bad-looking guy not a bad-looking
I heard he's on there though they weird
like he's on there because I feel like
you have to be a certain type of person
to be into that funny's is there you can
tell they've just been see better like
this thing Hey like a slight hesitation
when the thing is like is it 0.0 I guess
he's been waiting for all day
he already had a boner see when pants
were just all quit with it that's we
work on chin man by the way money you
know perfect dude you napur what else we
get justin trudeau
the appearing and brown face and black
face when he was younger
no go to dota and result doesn't make
them right then shows twitter cuz he
repos this guy goes it's great to see
Andrew Trudeau and Kim Jong at the
Academy all its make it's so funny
what are you son yeah he reposted he
retweeted keep going you'll see it keep
going
there it is look like comic said this
Justin Trudeau and Ken Jong I killing it
[Laughter]
as Mike I am Mike cannon shout out to
Mike cannon
what is that hilarious I just was
hanging out with Kim Jong he was so
funny he's so funny
nice guy yeah yeah we do man he wants
come on wish she was dressed like an
Arabic guy and he had brown face oh no
you better apologize really quickly for
appropriate disclosure dark and dressed
like an Arab you get the [ __ ] out of
here I don't know charcoal I know it's
[ __ ] hilarious
brown face I think or was it this is a
black face yeah and then he like so what
I am seemed like he was dressing like a
certain to sing a gym it Jamaican folk
song yeah okay pick up your past
different it's like the [ __ ] man Dave
Chappelle's thing like oh no matter what
you did way back then we're going to
[ __ ] now consider you a racist
this is [ __ ] anyway who's to who's
posting this stuff time you [ __ ]
idiots you want some quick ones I mean
Michelle [ __ ] at the Emmys talking
about equal pay and thank you and get
the [ __ ] out of here you watch the Emmys
all huh I watched her speech that I just
shut the [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] what I'm not a
big deal let's just look at this they
have a brontosaurus biology lab they
were making baby brontosauruses no this
is this is all yeah no this is [ __ ] off
there's it lemurs yeah they just do even
back when they do it in reverse but it
looks like a little baby brontosauruses
they do right especially this part I was
like holy [ __ ] those little
brontosauruses how awesome is that dude
what if they were little time you know
what we're Lee Moore's are indigenous to
Madagascar that's cuz of the movie good
job you know stupid oh good that you
watch that Disney show you [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't act like you knew that
I didn't know that man coitus koalas
Madagascar is where God what do you
think come on now
where is Madagascar tell me Madagascar
is in does anyone know cases you don't
know is Madagascar in Africa nope
no where would that I'm at again it's an
island well I know that good job
you know it's a night off of Africa off
of F good yeah so that's the animal not
lemur cody KO Atty whatever that is
that's a lemur isn't it I don't know
type of lemur yeah nothing's on the
South American coast all right what else
we got you those did look like baby
Brian for a second there's more animals
here I saw this holy [ __ ] it looks like
it's uh it's kind of cruel it seems
there's just a bunch of photographers
and they're following this orangutan a
giant orangutan who tell me they're
really das don't better they're really
also that they're feeling just doing
this chill and he's standing up that's
God I'd love to see must reach those
people but that looks like it's is it's
a sanctuary look at this dude how the
National Park uses that code is towards
the camera dude so there's that and then
this is for the side so this is the
video of him walking he was standing up
so look like kind of like super tomato
though huh look at it though you don't
attack anyone or anything nah he's
coming towards him you know I mean and
the other ones of the photographer gone
into the woods and this thing is when
he's on the trail dude but see like
there that looks trippy that would be
like Bigfoot but a tiny Bigfoot look at
how long it's not anything cool and then
check out this bison that runs by a
people on a truck
and Yellowstone National Park will call
fast isn't it hit anybody look at the
beauty of it watch it's so scary if
there's going this fast if you hit the
truck boom
laughs fastest way did he like it's just
a massive people yeah at the end picks
strong over two thousand pounds running
that fast yeah you're right next to
trouble bang some trouble you can
imagine what it'd be like and lastly I
didn't know about his handle more animal
hurting or somebody like me hit but
though these I've never seen animals
this adorable and they're in Australia
so when you gotta let just roll you have
to check these oh ho cus he looks
friendly right ah are they mean though
no they're actually a lot of super
friendly you're not supposed to touch
him why not you're not I guess that's
the rule there maybe you don't want to
get too comfortable with human beings
they don't want them to why I think it's
cute I don't probably know I would love
her so but look how cute these things
are and let her love a pet that's so
Frank okay but the only downfall of
these animals is that the mothers they
have like a few Joey's and if they're
chased by a predator what do you think
they do out so she can escape what a
selfish I know that's always sad part
about it but they're adorable
take my baby not me look at their faces
they're so friendly hey is that J sob
that thing is cute I want one I'll take
one can you buy them they do look like
my brother a little bit hey see if
they're on sale no you can't they're
from for salad go to the black white
Hedgehog looks like those those a little
bit with a pointy ur nose though but
these guys have like a real legitimate
happy like to smile Fred they're really
cute they're cool that thing is cute as
chandeliers are with this Joey no it's
not that
oh it's got a baby on its belly yeah mom
that's crazy whenever there's stress is
ditch the babies I thought that'd suck
pretty easy to kill yeah well and
there's they're so friendly they walk up
to humans just are curious the kids to
walk up to you right now take one right
just walking up hold on
I want one no no let's see if it another
commuter or good Australian get one dude
bring your bag with this [ __ ]
just get a hamster Talan spike goddamn
ham see if you can ask Eric walk on let
me say nope sorry and have long decline
declining wonder whether declining free
cuz they're slowin yeah they're just
slow and friendly doesn't work out for
anybody
yeah dude just get a hamster and shut
your [ __ ] yo get I get a gerbil dude
be a 50 year old with a gerbil uh-huh be
the 52 year old with a pet gerbil chicks
love that [ __ ] all right
welp that that's it Bryan County Tampa
this weekend the 27th 28th Tampa improv
come see me premium a pet hamster and I
will be in Denver this Thursday Friday
Saturday and next week I'm in Pittsburgh
Philly the week after that and then
November Dallas in Salt Lake City and
then this Wednesday 10:00 a.m. the new
tour 50 shades of brown a bunch of dates
posted on my Instagram and Twitter
including London UK Ireland Amsterdam
Sweden a bunch of dates on there Toronto
New York Boston Connecticut New Orleans
Washington DC 9:30 club nice Cardiff
Manchester Birmingham Newcastle London
Glasgow Belfast cool Dublin hork Norway
ants damn get tickets now
but all those presale use the presale
code buzz and also regular sale for
general public is Friday Jay have the
dates on their tea fat K calm love you
guys be go see them in Tampa yes sir
bring him pet hamster just a fine kid oh
we got our new advocating Fight Club
hoodies as well yeah softest shits are
yeah yeah this fun kid route